prices are increasing all around us and
NB energy and Southwest Gas are planning
a rate hike starting in January that
increase will average about 26 dollars
more per month Madison Kimbrough shows
us the reasoning though behind the
increases and how people are reacting
locals I spoke to said regardless of the
holiday season seeing prices climb like
this is concerning for their household
it's up to 280 sometimes it's almost 300
and I can't even afford that single mom
Elva Gutierrez struggling like so many
nevadans to afford the basic necessities
necessities like heat for the house
during the holiday season in a filing
with the puc NV Energy and Southwest Gas
say customers will see their electric
bills go up more than 14 percent with a
single-family home paying just under
23.50 more each month on average gas
bills will go up too by 4.8 percent
adding 2.76 to a typical single-family
home Bill locals across the valley who
don't have that extra money to spend now
having to figure out ways to cope and
sharing what they've gone through my
sister and I live together and we are
both on a fixed income they uh since the
summer the bill went from 150 something
to
312. now that it's getting cold at night
we're in the 400 dollars and we don't
have that kind of money the lights in
our house and electricity got cut off
earlier this year for at least like
maybe a week or two due to how high and
out of nowhere the prices they just went
up some type of energy assistance
program we try to get in that's that's
the only way because I'm I got a family
of five and I'm the only one working so
it's it's hard both utilities say they
do have Assistance programs for people
having trouble paying but what's the
reasoning behind the increase both say
it's because of the rising cost of
natural gas they also say they aren't
making any profit off of it just know
there is a way to keep your payments
stable and as for those financial
assistant programs we mentioned if you
need help we have that information up on
our website at 8newsnow.com reporting
near Sahara and Jones Madison Kimbrough
back to you